okay
here we go
thank you so much for coming what an
amazing turnout
my name is leslie knope i am the deputy
director of the parks and recreation
department and tonight we're going to be
taking some of your questions as hello
we're having a meeting in here
does anybody have any questions about
permits
we don't need palaces
the ideas are what shine in our meetings
what are you some kind of why
don't you have hand dryers in the park
bathrooms they're so much more sanitary
than paper towels anyone knows that my
dog went to one of your parks and ate
another dog's feces and i am going to
sue you for that
how do you like it
no how do you like that now imagine
you're holding coffee with the
government shut down who's going to stop
al qaeda
one thing at a time i don't like
obscenities just as much as you don't
like oh it drives me crazy i have kids
right but i've got my little
three-year-old i'm going through the
park and someone's like hey mike the
guys you my
head these people are members of a
community that care about where they
live so what i hear when i'm
being yelled at is people caring loudly
at me
nutrium's energy bars are just
absolutely loaded with high fructose
corn syrup and fatty oils and any way
you slice it they're just extremely
unhealthy for you
leslie needs to butt out the whole point
of this country is if you want to eat
garbage balloon up to 600 pounds and i
have a heart attack at 43 you can you
are free to do so
to me that's beautiful
any questions
if sugar's so bad how come jesus made it
taste so good uh
yes but isn't all food bad for you i've
been eating lasagna and muffins every
day of my life for 40 years and i feel
terrible right what's so bad about corn
syrup it's natural corn's a fruit syrup
comes from a bush oh boy
how do we know you're really a nurse i
am i promise i work at st joe's well the
point is my friend thinks you're cute
give me your number so he can have it
yeah that's not gonna happen can i have
your email address i just got on aol no
i think we ought to throw those bars out
and eat ham and mayonnaise sandwich
that's not a good idea ham and
mayonnaise
so that's what today's forum is for
we're gonna hear suggestions from
everyone and then whichever items we
generally agree on will go into the time
capsule
please remember this is a government
project so we need to refrain from
corporate promotion and religious items
who'd like to start
i think we should put in the bible
great
okay anyone else yeah if we put a tax on
soda i mean what's next income sir you
don't pay your income tax whether or not
i pay income taxes none of the
government's business no well
no actually it is well you don't know my
name or what i look like so good luck
finding me anyone else
anyone uh this gentleman wants to say
something
no i don't come on mel you're always up
in arms about something no i'm not i'm
not always up in arms about something
here we go that's the spirit talk to me
about what's bothering you okay are
there any more recommendations for new
games at the rec center my daughter she
loves shoots and ladders oh come on
there is no strategy to shoots and
ladders it's just luck my daughter's
five well your daughter is an idiot her
daughter is an idiot her daughter is an
idiot her daughter isn't it it's the
only park in our neighborhood i mean
where are my kids supposed to play the
rock quarry
there's rocks in there
why don't we just set fire to the fats
you know set it ablaze
that's arson well let's leave that up to
lawyers point is it would work why don't
we build a fence around their fence
why it would give us
two fences
so if they needed to get to their fence
for maintenance and whatnot their pants
might get caught let the filibustering
begin i would now like to share some
ideas i have for j.j abrams seventh
chapter in the star wars saga panned
down from the twin sons of tatooine we
are now close on the mouth of the
sarlacc pit after a beat the gloved
mandalorian armor gauntlet of boba fett
grabs onto the sand outside the sarlacc
pit and the feared bounty hunter pulls
himself from the maw of the sand beast i
think we should tax all bad things
like racism
and women's vaginas we're not taxing
anyone's genitals what the hell are we
doing here
come on boys
hello can everyone hear me okay no no no
okay great i'm councilwoman leslie knope
and today we are here to talk about safe
sex i know this is a personal question
but how many of you out there are
sexually active
oh mike i have two partners often at the
same time wow thank you does anyone know
what we risk
when we have unprotected sex heart
attacks
on top broken
you yes but the truth is the greatest
risk you face is sexually transmitted
diseases are these old people really
having sex with each other yeah what did
you think they were doing i don't i
don't we're just talking about it
oh
best way to prevent them is to use
protection well that's all fine and good
but what if the banana is soft and mushy
and dog legs sharply to the left
oh if he holds the reality gem that
means he can jump from different
realities this will be our link to the
marvel universe from the star wars
universe all taxation is theft if the
government can tax me i can i can do
this
grover give that woman her purse back
there's a lot of pill bottles in here
okay
imagine those two going up against robot
chewbacca because that's gonna happen
after a beat luke says darth vader was
my father but ben kenobi was my master
and he cuts hannah blechter in half okay
my name is ron
you don't need to know my last name
whoever wants to talk go ahead and we'll
be out of here in a tight 15.
i found a sandwich in one of your parks
and i want to know why it didn't have
mayonnaise
what's so funny oh yeah i don't think
kids should be allowed on the playground
equipment okay we've been over this if
you're worried about swine flu use hand
sanitizer i'm not worried about swine
flu i already have the swine flu i'm
worried about the turtle flu
turtle flu turtle food
turtle flu
is this gonna be a topless park
i don't think there are topless parks
well let's build the first one and be
heroes if this is going to be a topless
park i won't sign your petition if she's
going to the topless park i'm not signed
into the topless park petition
you know i take that back i'm still in
what's up i'm harris
yeah yeah forget whatever that uh pawnee
commons is i'm with that pervert topless
park
topless park topless park topless park
bjorn lurpis of the pawnee lerpis family
they were supposed to be a paunch burger
and there's a lot next to my house and
then you strip my freedom by putting a
park there now if i want to start my day
off with a triple decker pancake
breakfast pizza i gotta go to one that's
10 minutes away and that makes me 20
minutes late to work every day
i work at home have you ever considered
not eating that for breakfast i'll never
consider that
school is out in two weeks what am i
going to do with my kids all day keep
them in my house
where i live i think the slogan should
be pawnee home of crackers the oranges
goldfish in indiana okey dokey no let me
write it down who even needs a slogan
well now that is an interesting point no
that's my slogan idea who even needs a
slogan and then a big picture of me
flipping everybody off look we don't
know what the world is going to be like
in 50 years we we could all have been
wiped out from disease or the flu
so what's your suggestion
i don't know
i'm just scared
my idea for a slogan is
when you're here then you're home well
that's lovely i actually had it printed
up so we could see what it would look
like oh you um there's that's that's
spelled wrong that should be then
t-h-e-n stay strong let them work it out
and trust larry trust larry are you even
listening to yourself i like that slogan
a lot
but
you made a little mistake there she's
gonna she's gonna work it out you're
right
back off
you're misspelled wrong it should be
y-o-u-r
oops i didn't catch it thank you my
grandmother lived in pawnee for 60 years
and
i want to put her ashes in the time
capsule my cat
turnip was the greatest cat ever and i'd
like to put his ashes in the time
capsule for the last time and i won't
say this again
there will be no human or feline ashes
in either one of the time capsules
except for turnip
except for turnips no chanting can we
see the condom demonstration again
because i don't know where lou has been
well i i i wish i i
i could but i
i'll screw it okay here
this is a penis right you put a condom
on it and you pull the tip like this and
you roll it all the way down the penis
tell you what condoms for everybody who
wants them
you